uh so i'm gonna talk about another one
called closet tools
so closet tools is kind of similar to um
key values and that what i like about it
is that it's a very prototypical indie
hacker story
the founder his name is jordan o'connor
uh
he again doesn't have any co-founders
didn't have any investors
doesn't have any employees just one guy
and his pajamas building his app
and he also uh you know
came from sort of an underdog background
where he had tens of thousands of
dollars in student debt he was married
he had kids he had a full-time job
he just didn't have a lot of time and at
a certain point he was like you know
this is crazy like i've got to dig
myself out of this hole
uh and so he just started waking up a
few hours before his family every single
morning and just learning web
development
and he would learn by like reading
tutorials and taking courses and then
just going out and trying to help people
and for three years he didn't he didn't
make a single dime he would just wake up
early and build things online
to help people who needed help and sort
of the last person who needed his help
was his wife
she was selling her clothes on this
platform called poshmark not sure if
you're aware of it but you can
basically sell your used clothes to
other people and she was like this just
takes forever i have to share
you know my closet on poshmark to my
feed uh and he's like well i can
automate this you know i'm a web
developer now let me look at it
and so we automated it and one thing led
to another and eventually created this
business that's making him forty
thousand dollars a month in revenue
pretty much all profit he's pretty much
no expenses uh from all of these like
poshmark fanatics
who love using this tool that makes them
more productive and what i love about it
is that
uh essentially poshmark itself is like
creating a sort of
uh sort of widening the top of the
funnel of entrepreneurs by allowing
people
who don't really want to learn to create
anything to build an online business of
their own
and then what jordan's doing is he's
coming in and he's building a tool to
support the people on this platform and
it's not even like an officially
supportive tool like possmark doesn't
have
uh an app store they don't have an api
you just sort of hack this together
and people are using this tool to make
more money and so i love this pattern of
people looking at these platforms that
are helping other people succeed
and building tools for them whether it's
youtube
or only fans or twitch uh all of these
people are
super story of paypal you know according
to sax and
and teal and everybody over there was
they you know ebay didn't have this and
then of course ebay winds up buying them
eventually and what became
one of the great under one of the great
acquisitions ever and talk about an
underpriced asset uh every time i
talk with saks about it he's just like i
can't believe we sold so early you got
to ride your winter's daniel thoughts on
closet tools
what i love is to kind of pull up your
bootstraps and figured out how to code
and made a business like
all on your own by waking up a couple
hours early
very much the jocko willing energy just
applied to the internet
uh which i think is great um i also
think like
i mean to me it's awesome that the
internet is big enough
that we can support like a browser
extension can support
an individual because you know like the
common venture bet you know of a honey
acquisition aside it's like a browser
extension who would care but the
internet is so big now and by the way
it'll
still double um we still have three
billion people that aren't on it um
is that that yeah you can build a
browser extension and you can like live
off that uh
and i don't know i i just think that's
awesome to me it's really exciting to
think about the fact that
there will literally be 10 million of
these in our lifetime people who just
like figure out how to code and
i don't know so it's not particularly
intellectual of a comment but it's just
enthusiastic that's my
that's my kind there's a lot of these
very profitable browser extensions like
i talked to a lee moana who runs streak
which is kind of like a crm that sits in
your inbox
yes and he went through yc i think a
year after i did back in 2012
and he's grown the company like many
millions in revenue very profitable
with a pretty decent sized team and
again just like a browser extension
which you know five ten years ago you
wouldn't imagine anybody paying any
amount of money for
uh i pay for i think three or four
different browser extensions uh
grammarly
which i i experience mostly through a
browser extension
my password manager i would say which
one but there's a number of them that
are all pretty obvious
uh and i have one called push bullet i
pay for push bullet was a really
interesting one
i'm not an investor and i don't know the
founder but i was looking for a way for
my chrome os desktop to talk to my
iphone to talk to my ipad to talk to my
windows desktop to talk to my
mac desktop or whatever you know i'm
always on all these different gadgets
and devices and what it does is
whatever web page you're on if you press
the push but push bullet button it sends
it to all your other
devices because you know when you're
kind of like okay get stick on my
android phone how do i get it
cross-platform airdrop it's a crossbar
exactly
and it's just amazing last year alone
false declines cost the u.s uk french
and german markets over 20
billion dollars with a b false declines
are what happens when an
online purchase is declined when it
should have been accepted this
is something that anybody who's running
an e-commerce company
knows about and that's why if your
business takes payments online you need
to check out
checkout.com right a great domain name
checkout.com
they de-silo the payment process their
modular cloud payment platform
is ideal for businesses looking to
delight customers
and unlock new revenue streams
checkout.com will give you the insights
you need so you can optimize your
customer experience get more out of
every transaction and gain a granular
understanding
of how cash flows in and out of your
business
and with checkout.com your business can
innovate adapt to your markets create
outstanding customer experiences
and make smarter financial decisions
faster
big brands like adidas and samsung trust
them but check out loves to support
growing businesses that's why they're
here on this week in startups and
support their digital transactions so
they just raised a
450 million dollars seriously at a
15 billion dollar valuation they're not
going anywhere they know what they're
doing
learn more at checkout.com twist and see
if their payment solution works for your
business
you can even create a free test account
to see how their dashboard works and
it's very beautiful and elegantly
designed so go ahead and check out
checkout.com twist make sure you go to
checkout.com
twist